Because this project has multiple classes, I have to select the one that I
want. And now, I can scroll through in the usual way and see the methods of the
rectangle class. But I want to go a little bit above that and here you see a
summary of the constructors. There are two constructors, the first one takes no
arguments and constructs an empty rectangle. The second one takes four
arguments. And I can click on it, and I get the detailed description of what
each of the arguments are. To construct objects in a Java program, you also use
the new syntax. Let's have a look. Over here, you see a variable whose name is
box, whose type is rectangle. And the keyword new tells us to make a new
rectangle with these values for the construction. Now you know all the details
about construcitng objects.